veamos si podemos factorizar 45 x
cuadrada menos 125 la verdad yo cuando
veo una expresión de esta forma que
tenemos aquí el término x al cuadrado y
después un símbolo de menos lo primero
que viene a mi mente es la diferencia de
cuadrados la recta de dos cuadrados ok
ya hemos visto un montón de veces seguro
te vas a acordar que porque producimos
aquí a cuadrada menos b cuadrada esto se
factorizar como además ve a más b por a
menos b a menos de que esta fórmula
seguro ya te la sabes de memoria y pues
esta expresión me recuerda muchísimo a
esta diferencia de cuadrados entonces
podría pensar que la factorización de
esta expresión se parece mucho a esta
factoría ción ahora 45 no es un cuadrado
perfecto ni tampoco 125 entonces la
relación
esta expresión y esta fórmula no es tan
directa ahora algo que también salta a
la vista y que está muy interesante es
que ambos números 45 y 125 son múltiplos
de 5 entonces vamos a factorizar ese 5 y
veamos si lo que nos queda ya se ve más
parecido a este pedazo de la fórmula
entonces vamos a poner por aquí un 5 que
está multiplicando a haber 45 x cuadrada
entre 5 eso es igual a 9 por equis
cuadrada frei porque 5 por 9 45 y
después menos 125 entre 5 20 5 entonces
fue muy bueno eso de factorizar el 5
porque estos dos números de aquí ya son
cuadrados perfectos acá hay tres por
tres nos da 9 y 5 por 5 nos da 25 y de
aquí el camino ya es muy fácil porque
entonces esta expresión ya es igualita a
esta expresión
podemos decir que esto de aquí es a
cuadrada y esto de aquí es be cuadrada y
bueno si esto de aquí está cuadrada
entonces es igual pues 13 x por 3x nos
dan 9 x cuadrada entonces a tiene que
ser 3x y b tiene que ser igual a 5
porque 5 por 5 nos da 25 entonces esta
fórmula nos dice cómo factorizar este
paréntesis pero no se nos puede olvidar
el 5 entonces vamos a poner por aquí 5 x
y bueno esto de aquí se factorizar como
además b por a menos b entonces aquí
vamos a tener a más
por a - p donde a es 3 x 3 x 3 x y b5 y
c5 de 5 aquí ya tenemos además b y a
menos b y listo
esta es la factorización de esta
expresión de aquí